good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast and happy thursday
it's the thursday before a long weekend
it is our last show of the week yeah
very exciting the thursday before a long
weekend the long weekend i already broke
out my white pants you're ex being
extremely brave breaking very hasty
fashion police white pants white pants a
few days before memorial day
big deal but i actually got a targeted
ad for these and i was influenced
and they're so gorgeous they're spanx
they're like these white pants trouser
slash jeans that
don't
you can't see through anything they're
so thick
and honestly i was influenced and
it was the real deal i'm feeling very
glad with my purchase there's something
about those targeted ads they know me
better than i know myself of course like
all the
clothes baby clothes like makeup they
just start constantly serving me premium
content even though they're
eavesdropping on my entire [ __ ]
livestream
no like if i say today
let me say something that i would like
never said like scream it and choose
something that i would buy what's
something i would never buy ferrari i
want a ferrari i would love a ferrari
they're just the most gorgeous cars yeah
i have my license so i can't wait to
drive my ferrari when i get one good
girls drive ferraris oh sickening
sickening we've got a great show for you
guys today jax is back thank you so much
i know you had a really rough day
yesterday and we at the morning toast
support yesterday's episode was fabulous
we missed you but we got through it yeah
now you're back i'm back it was a very
rough day yesterday we also did record a
podcast together for the patreon in
general q a um and it's just been a
really
shitty week like on a larger scale you
talked about the uvalde mass shooting
yesterday and it's just like making me
so sick no there's like a like a
heaviness and like
and i think everyone can feel it yeah
and so i commend you for doing a show
yesterday because i i like well it's
been permeating like every single
thought i know i wasn't sure like
whether it was inappropriate or not um
because honestly like there was an
element that i was like how can we
literally talk about anything else right
but i think it's really like messing
with people and like people are getting
you know what sucks it's like this is
becoming so frequent it's like i think a
lot of people also feel desensitized
which is horrible so i just wasn't sure
what the right thing to do yesterday was
i'm glad we did a show we were able to
talk about it a little and then just
like take everyone's minds off of it
yeah um but yeah there's just like a
terrible um
like feeling in the air for everyone
yeah it's
so heartbreaking
everything that's come like these kids
their pictures and the teachers it's so
sad they can't i know
anyways
i just would feel rdh if yeah we didn't
talk about it today
and
we do have a good show we actually have
some good stories finally well you know
yesterday we had some like we had bad
stories yesterday but that's because i
tried to tailor them like the [ __ ] we
are so invested in like brian literally
doesn't know who we're talking about so
i had to pick the story it's like to be
a little tailored to brian which i liked
it okay you have to meet people where
they are yes and also like i think when
you have a guest co-host or a guest like
lean into what their expertise is like i
don't even have global entries so we're
not going to talk like i'm not a travel
expert whatsoever i'm probably the
opposite of a travel expert like doing
everything do you even have tsa
pre-check no that's not literally
disgusting do you have clear though
and zach has pre-check and he has no
problem going through without me yeah
that's me ben i'm like man i will
literally meet you in the lounge i know
but i have clear and i don't think he
does ben has clear ben has what you have
clear no tsa pre-check i have clear and
tsa preaching i pretty much get there
around the same time yes i completely
agree um but yesterday i did apply for
global entry i'm waiting to be like
accepted yeah i need to do that as well
because i'm tired of taking out my
computer my ipad and my shoes
and my shoes of course i can't believe
you still do that i haven't done that in
years i know also like the computer ipad
kindle they don't all fit in one tray
got it so you can't stack them no you
can't stack them they'll literally come
for your neck yeah they're crazy
and there's so i feel like in tsa
precheck line like maybe they're a
little kinder or because like there's
less to do things just go more smoothly
because somebody gets so [ __ ] fed up
let me tell you about your outline i
know why in the general airport security
line if you're if you're in that line
that means you don't have pre-check you
don't have clear like you don't have a
bunch of the like fancy traveler things
so you're not a regular traveler and you
don't know the rules so it's really like
[ __ ] central in that line and the tsa
pre-check slash clear line is filled
with frequent travelers you know exactly
what to do yeah take your belt off like
these are people who have done this many
times and they know what to do so it
moves more seamlessly so the tsa
agencies don't need to be so strong and
they also have less to do so not only
are they able to do it but there's less
so it really shouldn't be tsa pre-check
and nazi sap check it should be morons
and not morons and you're calling me and
ben morons well
yeah well yeah well if you don't have
tsa pre-check like i don't know what
you're doing did you hear that your
credit card like will
give you a rebate for it so it is
literally free she called mommy and
[ __ ] streisand bryce bryce and strikes
are here
inspiring in spirit um which is so good
these pillows these comfort pillows
someone asked where they're from i have
no idea okay the tag says handmade but
it also says art mom
so it says art mon
so do without what you will and these
were gifts from toasters at claudia's
show so please speak up in the comments
if you can shannon molly and shannon and
so that other people can get their
comfort pillows yeah they're really like
a burst of joy they really really are
much like the men themselves
so we have a lot to talk about real
housewives of beverly hills was on last
night and i want to give like a
comprehensive recap but i'm physically
unable because i have no idea what went
down in that episode i was trying to
follow everyone's like arguments about
hypocrisy and like relating it back to
their own feelings and validating
feelings and i have literally no idea
what happened same but do you know how
sometimes when like people are having a
conversation
and you like feel like they did that to
you but it's
i mean it's hard to see it from
crystal's point of view
but i feel like i know that feeling of
being like you guys are talking about
exactly what you did to me and what
about me but it wasn't exactly what like
she was her jump to make her situation
similar to sutton's was like extremely
large and i couldn't follow it
fair no i agree i really couldn't follow
it and i also don't know
like who's said i'm on in general like
who i want to see thrive because
sometimes it's sutton and then other
times it's like and i also really want
to like diana but she's coming in like
on rena's team and she came in just like
randomly going against sutton and then
they had to get in the car together
right now but then she was like she was
going against sutton but then she was
also like but sudden always apologizes
like right where do you stand and why do
does everybody else i don't know why i
feel like i want
like to like diana so much and i feel
like the women like want diana to like
them yes they want diana on their side
like she's coming in in a really strong
position
so she's well respected yeah
it's because she has a lot of money yeah
but they all have a lot of money like
son came in with a lot of money yeah and
they don't feel that way about something
because she came in weird like right no
there's like something just cool about
it yeah she's a cool factor for sure she
does it's like the european rich thing
yeah but it's also just her personality
because all of these women are wealthy
they all have wealthy friends and they
all run in cool circles like there's
you know so they're they're pretty much
used to that well we'll get into it in
the tv recap um but before that i do
believe ages time for the fast five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
luminesce breeze we don't have a ton of
time to get ready in the morning so
we're always looking for a way to put on
makeup faster and easier it's impossible
for us to find the perfect tone of
makeup because it never matches so
that's why you've got to check out
luminess and their new breeze cordless
airbrush makeup the breeze is a
completely touchless way to put on
foundation and it's so fast and easy to
use no sponges brushes or fingers
required with luminesce you get three
times more coverage while using 10 times
less makeup it's designed to work with
all skin types skin tones their water
based foundation is quick and easy and
it covers fine lines wrinkles it
conceals imperfections and it applies
flawlessly in seconds they have 18
shades so they've got a color for every
skin type and they will replace your
shade for free if it doesn't match their
product is cruelty free it's made in the
usa and it has an 18 hour wear so
there's no need to reapply your makeup
in the middle of the day also i love how
portable it is like when i'm on tour
it's really not that big you throw it in
your cosmetics case you can throw it in
your purse touch yourself up at work
it's really like the new way of doing
makeup
and it's super clean hands-free and it's
really fun so if you've been looking for
makeup that doesn't feel heavy or look
cakey on your face you will find it with
luminesce breeze airbrush just like we
did whether you're heading back to the
office updating your beauty routine or
just looking for a better faster way to
put on foundation we've got good news
right now if you go to breezetoday.com
toast and put in promo code toast you'll
receive 50 off the airbrush makeup
system plus free shipping and because
you're a listener here there's a special
free eyeliner valued at over twenty
dollars included just for you that's
fifty percent off plus free shipping
when you go to breezetoday.com
toast and put in promo code toast don't
forget you get 30 days to try out the
luminesce breeze and if you don't love
it send it back for a full refund
great okay our first story we have a lot
of young hollywood news today and
they're all sort of intertwined i love
love as a striving member of young
hollywood i love talking about them
totally striving beyond striving
she's striving to be young she's
striving to be in hollywood and you know
what i'm getting further away from both
and that's just it's devastating
well jacob and lordy and olivia jade
genuinely are dating officially us
weekly reported on tuesday both the
euphoria star and the dancing with the
stars alum recently split from former
partners so they are reportedly taking
their new romance slowly they both got
out of relationships recently so they're
not rushing into anything says a source
uh they were spotted together playing
with a dog being just like so cute and
casual she was wearing a hoodie and
tights which was really shocking to me
yeah but that's how casual they are
right you know because there were so she
fell asleep in her outfit from the night
before and then just throw on a hoodie i
was like shocked just to like walk the
dog also like the socks and the sneakers
this is just giving like we've been
together a million times i don't care
how i look around him now yeah so it was
reported that they were like
maybe like hanging out it hasn't been
officially confirmed that they're dating
and now that it is like i can just say
how overjoyed i am yeah i think this is
the cutest couple i think they really um
emulate like fabulous young rich famous
like i love it yeah and they're also
really in different industries which
works because he's like very much tv and
film and she's an influencer social
media
socialite now honestly yeah so i think
that's a recipe for success like you're
not competing for shows you're not like
someone's having more success in one
arena and you guys can like balance each
other more so yeah i think this has all
the makings of
everything of the sortness it's just
they're so young so like i think
eventually you know
what they're not gonna get married and
this like group of young hollywoods who
all look alike they all date like
each other each other and they all all
the boys look like all the girls look
alike so
for me like this just reminds me like
when he was spotted with kaia gerber
well they were together yeah but for a
long time yeah and they remember those
red carpet pictures from oh from that
was it there was lacma but then there
was also like this like hollywood museum
that's like oh yeah okay it's like ella
county museum of arts or something
i
think um yeah sorry i was gonna be using
he was thought it was zendaya like twice
but i don't think it was ever actually
confirmed that they were dating um so
yeah it's just like this young hollywood
like train and i love it yeah because
they're all just so
gorgeous and whether you want to admit
it or not like watching beautiful people
be beautiful with each other is exciting
it is exciting i also love the height
difference like it's just okay let's
talk about it okay all great
relationships have like enormous height
differences i firmly believe that it's
so cute except like sorry not to be like
so heteronormative but like only when
the guy is taller why what about nicole
kidman and keith urban
relationship iconic relationships and
tom holland iconic relationship i think
it goes both ways i think you're right
something to think about something to
think about i just i love a height
difference i really do
yeah this picture is just like
everything right no i can't explain it
and i'm so happy for olivia i feel like
definitely coming off a few hard years
yeah um and then just to to exit
dating the hottest man in hollywood like
that
that takes courage it takes perseverance
and i'm just you love to see a girl
coming out of a scandal with jacob and
lordy on her arm like that doesn't
happen to anyone no did you see this
picture of her leaving his house after
spending the night
iconic no it's really she's not wearing
shoes it's really giving like we're
together this is my boyfriend
i don't give a [ __ ] what i look like
anymore around him yeah she's carrying a
lot of bags so it does look like he
won't give me a drawer but maybe they're
working there oh yeah or maybe it's like
her makeup and tings right just to film
a vlog right maybe it's her vlog
equipment right right right do you think
we'll like we'll get to a place where
like jacob laurie is in a vlog i'll i'll
literally die does she really even vlog
anymore like once every six months it's
so annoying she's a podcast yes so i
don't think i don't think so no i would
just love to see like you know weekend
in malibu vlog and then he's like in the
background making a cocktail or
something of course that would be
gorgeous that would be anyway so
speaking of jacob alardy and olivia jade
it does lead us into our next story
circumstantially austin butler is
finally addressing vanessa hudgens
breakup two years later so austin butler
he is a man about town right now elvis
we've been talking about it for six
years is finally coming out in june he's
in cannes he's on the cover of gq and
he's talking about his relationship with
vanessa hudgens which did span ten years
and then all of a sudden they're not
together it's devastating and then all
of a sudden they're not together and
he's reaching like his blowing up career
peak yeah and i wonder how that feels
for her it can't feel good
i feel like the whole time they were
together like she knew he was going to
be a star like she believed in him when
no one else did yeah and she gave him 10
good years of her life and then they
break up and he hits big
it ain't right no it ain't but he said
that life is full of changes you've got
to find a way to be constantly evolving
and growing like for a while vanessa
hudgins was the only thing keeping
austin butler relevant like if he if
they hadn't dated and i wasn't like
weirdly obsessed with their relationship
i literally would have forgotten he
existed yeah but then he was dating kai
gerber well no no i'm sorry now he is
dating hey gerber and kai gerber used to
take jacob lordy that's how everyone
knows it's this incestuous little young
hollywood crew and austin butler he's
doing a lot of press for elvis again
can't stop talking about it boss lerman
it's going to be the thing it better be
a good movie jackie you don't even have
tick-tock they have blown up on tic-tac
first of all they had a huge party last
night in cannes because it's cam can
film festival they flew out all these
tick tockers all these tick talkers are
making content they have a tick tock
account for elvis they were live
streaming the party like they are doing
the most on tick tock so if you think
you're seeing it a lot you don't even
know the half of it oh wow well him and
kaia like were smooching on the red
carpet dead okay austin butler is so hot
like
and you know what i haven't seen him act
since zoey 101 so i don't even know if
he's talented diaries you love gary
diaries that show was so good like
justice for carrie diaries even though
like the only problem with the carrie
diaries was that it was supposed to be a
sex and the city prequel and like anna
sophia rob and sarah jessica parker like
no it wasn't working she wasn't giving
carry they both had curly hair but like
i could just not see this girl out of
sofia rob turning into the annoying
[ __ ] we currently know as carrie
bradshaw
that's the fatal flaw of the carry
diaries it should have been called like
the jackie diaries like it should have
been called literally anything else it
should have been called the jackie
diaries i agree maybe then it would have
gotten a third season probably not
because everything i love gets cancelled
so i just want to say like this moment
that austin butler is having met gala
can film festival kaya gerber this movie
like very here for it and we've been
talking about the elvis movie movie for
a while and like every young hot
talented actor in hollywood went out for
this role harry styles
he would have been great and the fact
that it was
austin butler like is so crazy and
random because he was like so
random only the only thing keeping him
in my opinion was vanessa hudgens yeah
so i actually am really sad that they
broke up even though i stan
him and kaya yeah me too agreed on all
counts
and i'm glad that the role went to him
because he wasn't a movie star before
and like now we have one more movie star
as opposed to it being harry styles who
like can't get any bigger right that's
true but i have to see the movie first
and i just want to say like i i've seen
a lot of like trailer footage on tick
tock
and i don't think it's fair to judge but
it's giving like
it's giving community theater no just
what i've seen really small clips of
honestly the clips that i've seen i'm
just like
no that's
not elvis like i can't explain it in the
sense like he doesn't really look like
elvis
interesting he does look like austin
butler like we're playing
montana yeah right i agree so i have to
see the movie i don't think it's fair to
make any judgments and i will be seeing
the movie
but
yeah i'm trying to look for a review
there was one on variety this morning oh
but also i don't um i don't care about
reviews i want to see the rotten
tomatoes audience me their score that is
the only true metric on the internet
period not even just covering movies
period yeah agreed
are you ready for our next story which
you're going to really take the lead on
because kate moss testified for ex
johnny depp she said he never pushed me
kicked me or threw me down any stairs
kate moss testified that johnny depp
never pushed her down any stairs when
they were dating in the 90s on wednesday
morning the british model appeared via
live video link
looking like a bachelor radiant in front
of the fairfax virginia courtroom to
address a reference that uh depp's
ex-wife amber heard made in previous
testimony about kate moss and upstairs
let me just give like for those who
don't know okay so in layman's terms
johnny and his team had wanted kate to
testify because they dated for a while
and she could testify that he was never
um physically abusive and
amber's team and they were right legally
it's irrelevant you know like it's not
about what he did to kate moss so they
weren't allowed to
have her testify but then when amber
heard was being was on the stand she
accidentally
brought up the staircase incident with
kate moss which then opened the door
once it's brought into the courtroom
then it's fair game so she brought it in
she like slipped up and that's the only
reason why kate moss was added in last
minute yesterday her testimony was super
short
three minutes in out nothing happened i
fell down the stairs we were in like a
water villa and the stairs were wet it
had rained i slept down the stairs
johnny picked me up threw me in the bed
not threw me in the bed put me in the
bed got me medical attention and
literally that's it during our entire
relationship he was never physically
abusive
but i've i've really gotten into the
trial recently because at first i was
getting all my information from tick
tock and
shockingly i don't feel like that's
accurate because then i started tuning
into the
the trial every day and if you just read
like headlines like even tmz is very pro
johnny if you read just headlines and
just like fan edits on tik tok you're
like oh johnny's winning this trial when
you tune into the trial i have just and
there everything everyone everyone was
saying was like amber's lawyers are like
backwards
yeah uh that's not really not what i see
i think they're doing like a pretty
decent job and and honestly johnny will
lose this case
and that's not because
in my opinion was he physically abusive
i don't know
but he will lose the case because the
point of the case in order it's very
difficult in order to win a defamation
trial johnny depp has to prove that he
was not physically abusive to amber and
a lot of what they're proving is that
amber was also physically abusive and
johnny wasn't abusive to his other
girlfriends like it's very hard to prove
that he wasn't
that what amber said was a lie
so even though k moss can help that
still doesn't prove that he didn't do x
amount of things to amber
so i've been watching it now getting
like a more balanced um
take from it i do think
johnny went into this case not with the
intention of winning but with the
intention of changing public perception
and i think that he has done that and i
think that is
fully complete now yesterday was also an
interesting day in the trial because a
staff member at tmz
had to testify and tmz like submitted
emotion like they don't want to be a
part of it yeah he got it got denied the
guy had to
um he had to testify and what he was
what they were testifying was like amber
had this relationship with tmz she was
the one who sold them you know the video
of the cabinets and slammed um
she obviously took that video and
there's proof that she sold it to tmz
and right now like the owner of that
video is tmz so they didn't really want
to be a part of it but there's like this
long paper trail of amber having like an
established relationship with tmz so the
guy had to get on the stand it was like
really awkward um so yesterday was like
a crazy day in the trial it is coming to
an end i think it's over tomorrow yeah
um and i don't think johnny will win
right so that will mean he has to pay
her lawyers right i don't know because
that's different in every state okay
so he's suing her for 50 million dollars
and she's then suing him for a hundred
so if
if he loses which i do predict because
it's really borderline impossible to win
a defamation suit i don't know what that
means for johnny and i know johnny has a
lot of money but i don't think he has a
hundred and fifty million dollars to
like give away yeah
got it well i do think especially now
that he's pretty much
according to his testimony unemployable
like no one will imply that's going to
change after this i i think it will too
i don't think people have ever like
loved johnny depp more than they do now
there's never like been more which is so
bizarre
it is so bizarre
he like lost that movie right because
right i think maybe it could be back up
for
because like how many people there's
like almost a million people watching
the trial live every single day like not
even waiting they're watching the
primary source they're not waiting for
like a tmz recap like there is so much
interest have you seen outside the
courthouse
like and it's all women and it's like
literally
like hundreds of women and he like rolls
down his window and he's waving it's
like it's not real like you know i think
that those people obviously were johnny
stands before but now even look at
someone like you who literally couldn't
give two shits about johnny before no
and i now you're like kind of like this
man has been wronged a little bit yeah
see i'm really struggling like with
where to land because
there's definitely a lot of evidence
that their relationship was mutually
abusive and like really tumultuous
um
but johnny's lawyers they are doing a
great job of like painting him
the way that i perceived him before the
trial is definitely different than how i
look at him now mm-hmm um
and it's just very confusing so i
imagine as a juror you're not gonna be
able to make
any sort of like 100
like proclamation
well it has to be like beyond the shadow
of a doubt yeah and it's not it's it's
every time her lawyers are up there i'm
like yeah and then his lawyers are up
there like yeah i would make a terrible
juror and a terrible lawyer because i'm
just like whatever the information in
front of me is i'm like oh my god that's
so true
that's so true no no i would be like i
would have literal whiplash you know
what you would say i see both sides yeah
is there an option for a juror to see
both sides but i think that makes a good
juror to see both sides no whatever jury
if i'm ever a part of like it will be a
hung jury like i will be there she will
hang this i will be that one [ __ ] i'm
like i really can't decide you guys but
i'm also like a loser who gets like
swept up to peer pressure so if everyone
was like no come on like we're team
amber i'll be like okay
sure whatever you guys say are we going
out after wait like we get drinks
jerry drink should we start a group chat
so it's just it's been a really crazy
like moment in pop culture yeah and to
see how like certain outlets are
reporting on it is really interesting
too like
tmz is like extremely
pro-dep um i saw an article vogue like
it's time we believe amber heard so all
these different outlets are taking
different sides and i just think what's
really being glossed over my major
takeaway from this is like i do think it
was extremely mutually abusive um but i
think a lot of like the the abuse that
johnny suffered gets like overlooked
because he's a man right and i think
like
that's just an interesting takeaway i
have and i'm by no means an expert these
are just my opinions um
it's just been a wild ride and it's
almost over and i don't even think i'm
not even like oh my god what's gonna
happen in the jury like it's fairly
obvious
i mean i just wish we could hear from
elon because
oh something very interesting elon came
up yesterday what did he do so there's
been this whole storyline so you know
amber got a seven million dollar
settlement from johnny in their divorce
okay and after she um you know wrote the
op-ed accusing him of physical violence
a lot of people were like well how could
you accept seven million dollars from an
abuser she was like you're right and she
said she was going to donate the money
to the aclu and the children's hospital
of los angeles she pledged the money and
it turns out
that um
those were just pledges the donations
were never actually made
so
amber's like you know
i will be pledging the money over time
blah blah blah but the all in all as a 7
million dollars we're really never
dispersed
allegedly but then there was this other
woman who was friends of johnny she was
like friend of johnny and amber she was
um
she's the head of a
non-profit called art of elysium and
when amber was like i'm giving my seven
million dollars to these two
organizations this woman was like really
pissed amber's had lived with her for a
while something they were really close
she was like i literally run a
non-profit like and almost really small
aclu is huge like you could have given
me something right and it was like this
whole drama with her relationship with
amber um and then like months later a
250 000 check came in
for art of elysium
on behalf of amber heard from elon musk
so elon is definitely in there there are
a lot of conspiracy theories that elon
is like allegedly there's no proof of
this the father of amber's child cause
amber has a a child um and she hasn't
been vocal about who it's with so
elon is in the mix
that's who we need to hear from
that's who could settle all of this but
i don't think we will no
not even in the trial a lot of the
theories are that first of all like why
would elon want to be a part of this
it's so messy elon every celebrity has i
don't know i could see you on wanting to
get in there
set the record straight so a lot what a
lot of the theories are is that you know
if hypothetically allegedly elon is the
father of
amber's child
and
elon might have you know some not
flattering things to say about amber he
wouldn't do that to the mother of child
like he wouldn't disgrace her publicly
judicially right um and that's why he
decided to you know wash his hands of it
got it
very interesting thank you there's just
so many celebrities involved in this you
know and it's crazy yeah
but i have to say some of you johnny
stands are like a little out of control
like i'm seeing like these fan edits
with like pirates of the caribbean music
of like johnny and his lawyer his lawyer
camille who like everyone is obsessed
with she's like this young hot associate
um she's great at her job and her and
johnny seemed to be very close and now
there's like fan edits and like fan
fiction being made up like as if they're
dating
oh my god
it's out of control honestly okay that's
where i draw the line like i'm not there
are you ready for our next story though
if it's a story that's brought to you by
splendid spoon it is what a splendid
spoon that is summer doesn't last
forever so why spend more time than you
need on meal planning grocery shopping
and cooking with splendid spoon you can
make more time to enjoy the season and
feel great with plant-based meals that
require no prep time splendid spoon
sends delicious plant-based ready-to-eat
meals and snacks right to your door
their meals are shipped to your door
ready to eat so you'll only lift a
finger to press start on the microwave
which is we were just talking about the
other day as someone who's literally
unable to cook one thing properly
splendid spoon is a brush breath of flu
breath of flesh
splendid spoon is a breath of fresh air
they fit into any schedule and there's a
meal plan for everyone and all their
meal plans are customizable so you get
what you want every time so their male
meals are 100 plant-based
i'm not okay she's just so excited about
splendid spoon you guys that she's
twisting up her words yes so they're 100
plant-based gluten-free and gmo free and
they're always made with plenty of
veggies legumes healthy fats whole
grains and spices from all around the
world so even though we're not
plant-based girlies we are kosher which
a lot of times like has a convergence
it's like diagram right exactly so
splendid spoon is actually really really
good for us
they have fresh takes on classic dishes
like vegan meatballs
marinara noodles or you can take your
taste buds on a journey with exciting
dishes like cauliflower tikka soup
they've got smoothies grain bowls soup
bowls and noodle bowls for you to
discover eating plant-based can come
with a wealth of benefits like improved
energy sleep digestion and complexion so
eat well enjoy more of your summer with
splendid spoon get started today and
save on an entire week of ready-made
plant-based meals just go to
splendidspoon.com toast for 50 off your
first box when you subscribe that's 50
off your um first box at
splendidspoon.com
toast thank you claudia
it's a pleasure
our next story jeff bridges is sitting
down with people magazine and saying
that he was pretty close to dying from
covid while he had uh was in chemo for
cancer right
jeff bridges has a lot to celebrate
these days he has a new grandson a new
puppy a new show and he'll be
celebrating his 45th wedding anniversary
but these days the oscar winner is
simply grateful to be alive after he
recently survived non-hodgkin's lymphoma
and nearly died of covid i forgot that
he was
going through that i forgot yeah in this
week's issue of people he opens up about
his towering year and a half that he now
calls a bizarre dream it began while he
was doing exercises one morning at home
and felt something unusual in his
stomach he went to the doctor and was
shocked by what they discovered he had a
12 by 9 inch tumor in his body like a
child in his body it didn't hurt or
anything
12 by 9. yeah that's huge huge he
was diagnosed with cancer and quickly
began chemo by infusion everything was
working the tumor began to shrink they
got he said quote they got a cocktail
that worked and oh man it worked fast
that thing just imploded but in january
2021 his health took a turn for the
worse when he got covered the chemo
treatment had weakened his immune system
and the virus hit him hard he spent
almost five months in the hospital where
he was in extreme pain and couldn't roll
over in bed without calling the nurse to
help him with oxygen
he said i was pretty close to dying the
god the doctors kept telling me jeff
you've got to fight you're not fighting
i was in surrender mode i was ready to
go i was dancing with my mortality
he began to see improvements after the
medical team gave him convalescent
plasma he started taking baby steps he
said each day brought more strength and
more hope he began working with a
physical therapist three times a week
and now he is doing well promoting his
new film the old man co-starring john
lithgow and amy brennaman wow that's a
crazy story crazy story and you know
jeff bridges is not like a you know a
celebrity we're often speaking of he
kind of lives a private life so i
totally forgotten that the last time i
really heard about him he was suffering
from cancer yeah so so much has happened
since then and i love jeff bridges he's
literally definition of a pee job
definition of a p john this is a crazy
story to spend five months in the
hospital and as you know a celebrity and
we don't even know about it like that's
how private he is right and i'm just so
glad he's out the other side
and
that we can have more wonderful work to
look forward to right like perhaps a
stick it sequel perhaps a stick it's
sequel maybe it's time yeah like all
these reboots all these sequels that
nobody asked for give the people what
they want give them stick it too give
them stick it too like how hard can it
be
it can't be hard
so twisted it's so offensive agreed
are you ready for our fifth and final
story
i think we could use a song today yeah
my triangle's all the way over there
do you want to go get it okay hold on
and i will entertain everyone with a
little bryce larp
bruno actually came to me this morning
and he said something so
so pivotal what do you say that he wants
to get his own apartment and move in
with magnolia
and i said bryce how you don't have a
job how are you gonna do that maybe show
up to work a little bit more said mom
can i work for you
no we're not hiring i said chief
cuteness officer that's a role that we
need to fill ready
it's the final story
you are not a
our fifth and final story is about some
of our favorite girlies who you'll never
guess oh let me think our favorite
you'll literally never guess i could
give you 1 000 guesses okay
sophia grace and rosie reflect on their
life-changing ellen degeneres show
experience okay i just want to say
they're not my favorite curlys like i
don't really like
even though people say we're sophia
grayson
grown up yeah i'm obviously sophia seen
that meme we've posted it it's like
oh sophia grayson rosie boy you got my
heartbeat running away
[Music]
you don't know that that's what people
say about us i had no idea literally yes
you're sophia grace like with the voice
yeah and the attitude and rosie just
like running sidelines
for the ride
and
they they look like us too no they do
definitely and have you seen these
pictures of them all grown up yeah of
course i saw them on the ellen show like
doing their um like little rap again and
it wasn't as cute no because now sophia
grace is 19 and rosie is 15 and they
reflected on their countless appearances
and both in which both viewers and
celebrities alike fell in love with them
uh
rosie said i was so little and so cute i
got hugged and kissed a lot
she was five when she first sat down
with ellen and she said she loved
meeting rihanna she pushed me up and
kissed me justin bieber kissed me on the
cheek and i also loved running around
backstage spying on other celebs like
jennifer lopez for sophia grace there
was one guy who she will never forget
interacting with on the red carpet after
covering the wardrobe for ellen she said
i saw drake come in and i literally
shouted drake oh my god we had candy we
were giving to all the celebrities and
he that's what we do
literal we are sophia
and he just kept eating all of them it's
weird because he's just a normal person
really people are really shook by the
new photos that have emerged of sophia
grace and rosie they're grown up and
they're like they're grown women they're
grown in women and they're like um
like a little thotty
no they're like
that's what 16 year olds look like now
yeah and the makeup and the extensions
and the long nails yeah they are like
instagram girlies and it's shocking when
you see like how we
know them as the girls in the tutus but
this is them now do you feel old yet yes
no extremely old and i have to say of
all the people who have gone viral and
like tried to make something of it i do
feel like they've had the like a really
ideal um
like life
yeah because it's like they had such a
great experience when they were kids i
think it was all good now you know now i
know what sofia grace looks like today
but if i had like run into her in the
store a week ago i wouldn't have known
and so she was able to really have the
best of both worlds normal life but with
also access to like incredible fame and
fortune yeah and now she has like some
really fun facts to share when she's you
know doing an ice breaker with her team
in the team building exercises i don't
know if she's in college or uni yet but
like if she is that's totally like two
truths and a lie i've been on the ellen
show 16 times i met drake and gave him
candy yeah and then the lie would be
like i'm a secretly a natural blonde you
know
[Laughter]
yes i do know
um also really quickly do you know what
i did yesterday evening
what i recorded an episode i was a guest
on
i wanted to ask you how it went on the
official twilight podcast tell me
everything posted by ashley green
obviously who plays alice and her best
friend and they just like talk to
castmates they talk to super fans and i
did like a little interview and it was
so much fun like i was getting like
hella choked up like what did you talk
about well because it's called the
twilight effect and so they're like what
has what has the effect been on you and
i'm like well and it obviously like the
premium content but like it really keeps
my family so close like we're so
obsessed when we go on vacation like the
only movie we can all ever agree on so
it's like i have like a wonderful
association obviously because i love
bella and edward and i love the whole
thing but also because like it it
reminds me of my family and she was like
oh man we hear that all the time
it was really and but i did make like
one major slip up oh god because it's a
show for super fans and i was there like
as you know a super fan um
and they were like which character like
would you play or i don't forget what
the question was but i was going through
the list of characters and i was talking
about nikki reed's character um what's
her name
uh rosalie okay i accidentally said
rosemary
and i was like
i'm supposed to be here as a superman
i'm like here i am calling rosalie
rosemary and i was so embarrassed and i
do believe they'll edit it out so i just
like exploited myself but like i was
just out here you know trying to be a
super fan and then making like
enormous enormous mistakes right okay
first of all i thought what you were
gonna say was gonna be so much worse no
um second of all they need to know and
they should tell all the listeners they
should do like a
a thing before that you have a really
terrible memory no i know and you can't
be expected to remember everyone's name
in the movie no but it was so weird
that's just too much for you how much
else i remember they were like what is
your favorite line i'm like i literally
had a thousand first thing about charlie
he doesn't have her
also i said like when i got married i
made ben watch edward's vows and i was
like you need to do this but better and
obviously he didn't but one of my
favorite lines from the movies from all
five movies is
no amount of time
will ever be enough with you
but let's start with forever and it's
like this double entendre because they
are going to live forever
um
it was just it was so fun like i really
enjoyed it when it was over i'm like
that's it that is so fun so i'm assuming
the second one that you shared from the
bow like other people it's their
favorite i'm sure yeah sure what she was
not expecting me to be like the thing
about charlie he doesn't have her i'm
like it's just like a weird line me and
my family like picked up like say
and you know what i also said it was
like perfect and people are either like
charlie or not like china and i said it
was the perfect
um
way to describe charlie because like he
was very protective but he was never
around you know he doesn't hover yeah no
he does not so i thought it was like an
accurate
character description it was really
really fun and it just made me want to
watch twilight again
which we should do
we should do a marathon we should go on
vacation
and watch it i was saying like for some
reason we only watch when we're on
vacation it's because we're all together
of course and we can never agree on
anything so after like 10 minutes of
scrolling we're just like twilight yeah
yep
did she ask what your favorite movie is
uh no she didn't you should just read
the books i know i she asked if i did
and i was like it when i was watching
the movies like you couldn't pay me a
million dollars to read a book now as an
adult with a kindle like it's on my list
of things to do and it totally is you
should i think you would enjoy it
immensely yeah no i think i would it's
like the only way to get more twilight
because there's more facts and figures
in the book i know there's actually like
a lot more allegedly yeah so that's how
you could get more twilight i know and
then you could also read midnight sun
which is the edward origin story i know
we also did like a whole 10 minutes on
peter fox oh
yeah what did she say and the whole time
i was like me and my sister are always
like this me and my sister are always
like done and she was like um
maybe the question was like
it was just something about the guys
like the guys being hot and okay i'm
surprised you remember like i don't
now that you're saying everything i'm
like yeah we have all these like things
and thoughts and feelings about twilight
maybe if i was doing a podcast i would
like sit down and try and remember all
of them but i forgot about peter fratch
well oh oh peter fatinelli is dr collin
oh oh well what i said i think it was
like you know who would you who do you
ship with yourself like from the cast
and i was like obviously edward but like
honorable mention because my sister was
telling me about this article she read
about like rich um the richest fictional
characters in tv history and carlisle
collins since he's been alive for so
long is actually like one of the top
five um so i would obviously marry him
and and she was saying how like so many
people like thirst out for peter fox but
only in recent years and i'm like well
here's why first of all he did that
people magazine spread with his like
stomach out with his like covered weight
loss with his covered weight loss like
two or three years ago and it was
life-changing for a lot of us really
life-changing and i think the whole
vampire aesthetic i'm like no one's
gonna even need to listen to the podcast
no but listen to it it was really good
and then we did like rapid fire
questions um
that whole like
vampire aesthetic like pale skin light
eyes like it really works for robert
pattinson some of the other characters
that made them look even hotter but i
think it made
carlisle like like not look so hot so in
real life when he's like brunette with
like regular color eyes you realize like
how hot he is yeah so it didn't people i
don't think came to the realization
until afterwards i think it's about the
audience growing up and you know when we
were younger we watched a movie yeah
like edward is this cool high school guy
but when you're older like you look at
the board and you're like carlisle
carlisle carlisle he has the stability
the money the family man
he you know has planes trains like it
was carlisle's plane that took them on
their honeymoon 100
and took them back on their honeymoon
exactly uh wait i had one more quest oh
did she had she read the books i didn't
ask but i gathered that she didn't
interesting
okay yeah i also told her my least
favorite movie was eclipse like the
whole newborn thing is so dumb she said
it's harley's favorite too because she
was barely in it
maybe that's why we didn't like it
either 100
did she know that carlisle is taught by
richard no she didn't know that factoid
oh my such a good guess i'll tell you
like he's been alive for so long
inflation
all that and no and al he uses alice's
abilities to see the future to predict
stocks right right right right yeah she
didn't even know the role she played in
his book she should come for her share
well she asked me a question and i won't
share because i'm spoiling the whole
interview but i'll ask you
whose
power of all like the
the cullens like whose power would you
want
that's a really great question i need to
think of everyone's so alice can see the
future i don't think i would want that
that's too much running through my mind
okay edward is super super strength
um no he can read people's minds
oh right right they're all strong yeah
um you know what i kind of i might want
bella's eventual power to protect the
ones i love
i okay i don't say what i said okay but
what'd you say i'll tell you later
no but i think that the point of the
podcast like obviously the toasters are
gonna go listen but like it's for her
audience too so so it's from i said i
would want jaspers jasper can change
other people's moods
so it's like if i'm in a bad mood like
[ __ ] you got to be in one too and if
i'm in a great mood like want to drink
and you don't want to i'm making you
drink oh yeah that's a powerful tool
yeah
okay cool so that'll be out i don't know
when but hopefully by the time it comes
out you forgot what i said here exactly
um and let's dive into the tv recap of
the real housewives of beverly hills
episode from last night which is brought
to you by ivory ella a lifestyle apparel
brand that donates 10 of its profits to
saving the elephants and other
charitable causes they were launched by
college students and ivory ella grew
organically into one of the largest
and most passionate communities of
supporters wanting to make a difference
in the world they've donated over 2
million to date ivory ella continues to
deliver good clothes for a good cause
she was launched by college students and
a high school teacher and they had a
super viral launch they sold 500 shirts
in 10 minutes and they've
donated over half a million in their
first year to save the elephants they've
over 2 million donated to charitable
causes in general and a minimum of 10
percent is donated on all their products
so every time you buy from ivory ella
you are making a donation to a cause
that is important to you some of the
charities they support are save the
elephants autistic self-advocacy network
cyber smile foundation reef restoration
foundation the american heart
association hearts and bones and more so
with everything you buy
you are helping save the world little by
little all of their clothes are super
cute really comfortable and very trendy
and you can become a part of the herd go
get yours with 15 off using code toast
at ivoryella.com
collections slash new dash arrivals so
again if you want that 15 off for cute
comfortable trendy clothes for you and
then also ten percent of the profits
going to
charitable causes um use code toast at
ivoryella.com collections slash new dash
arrivals all right real housewives of
beverly hills the girls go to palm
springs which is like becoming a
tradition i really like yeah it's funny
how we never went to kyle's house in
palm springs and now we're going every
year i do think that's also because of
covid yeah and i think the house is kind
of new no i thought you stole my goddamn
house i don't think that's the house oh
interesting but i'm not 100 maybe now
she has like a house that can
accommodate really almost everyone well
the only thing i i don't like is that
not everyone can fit in the house like
last time and this time there were
people staying at a hotel la quinta
where tasha season was filmed i know but
i feel like not everyone wants to stay
in the house because they could share
rooms if they really wanted to bunk
together but i do think the new girls
like want their own space yeah and diana
definitely doesn't seem oh is saying at
the house no she's at the hotel she
seems like someone who needs her own
space with her glam i thought it was
hearing how she travels oh my god beyond
interesting how she shops this woman
needs her own show because she has a
life that is unreal unreal like the fact
that she has hair makeup and assistance
and like housekeepers go to a place
before she does make sure the sheets are
good set up her glam unpack her clothing
get her food like a dream like literally
a dream when i check into a hotel i like
beeline in there i throw my suitcase in
the corner and i order a room service
and like go to sleep like right it
sounds so luxurious no she literally
lives such a fascinating life she was so
uncomfortable in a store yeah she didn't
know what to do with herself am i
supposed to touch this but i have to
imagine she went to a store before she
hit it big well i don't know because if
you think about it she like came from
this like war-torn country
she then lived in london like literally
taking any job to get by
like she's a dirt dirt dirt poor and
then in a flash
the one percent so
it's not entirely impossible that she
hasn't been in a store okay like if you
think about it yeah that's true i didn't
think about it that way because there
were 10 years while she was in london
before she got married but she said she
was literally scrubbing toilets right
right literally doing anything to get by
for pennies got it so she just has a
crazy story and i just love learning a
little more bits about like her
lifestyle like regular things that
happened even her six embryos that she
plans on having six more children
this woman needs her own reality show
i'm sorry i know
put her in like this group setting and
act her to just like and expect her to
act just like a lay person it's not
working no it's not working at all but
um she was a trooper she went on the
trip um
what happened before the trip like
nothing right oh they were they go over
to crystal's house and they're trying to
talk about sutton and i really respect
garcelle like being an actual good
friend like let's not talk about people
while they're not here to defend
themselves and none of us were there so
we can't defend her so it was
weird that kyle like brought it up out
of nowhere but then but then and i
thought um sutton did a really good job
at the store of like addressing it
diffusing it
and it really did not need to be spoken
about again so i don't understand why
garcelle brought it up she thought she
was doing sutton a favor somehow just to
like maybe show all the women that
dorite has forgiven sutton we can all
move on
yeah but like i don't know it felt like
it like really unnecessary yeah i agree
i don't think she did sutton any favors
no not at all but then it got so messy
that's what she thought she was doing
they are very good friends sutton and
marcel and so i think anything garcelle
was doing was just in like service of
being something a great just to show the
women like this has been put to bed i
know you all heard about it from kyle
now it needs to be closed with all of
you right because or else we'll just
keep talking about it for the rest of
the season right but then things went
off the rails things went off the rails
diana chimed in and i was like get out
of here um
like erica was loving the whole thing
because everyone was like ganging up on
sutton and it was just like it was over
i i just didn't understand what the
conversation
happening was about because it's over
right and i just don't know where i
stand like who do i want to see win
these arguments i really don't know i
found myself rooting for garcelle cut
sutton and crystal last night because
honestly i felt over like the last
couple of years
like just this disassociation from that
core group like
and i used to love them like kyle renna
erica dorit like those are my girlies
but i don't know i just
i don't feel that like kinship with them
anymore yeah i think because the group
is a little rotten now especially with
like rena and erica and it also seems
like they give no [ __ ] anymore about
even trying to be nice to new people or
whatever unless it's like diana jenkins
so like you literally have to be her in
order to get any soda in here and then
but you know that like kyle and dorit
and teddy are so close with them in real
life so it just sort of
pollutes the whole group for you see
teddy was weird i agree i gravitate
towards agreed uh i gravitate towards
sutton garcelle and they're just very
real no [ __ ] like then i don't agree
with sutton's reaction to the read
things and i don't agree with crystal's
weird breakdown last night right
but i think in my heart of hearts like
i'm secretly rooting for the new girls
yeah no i am too more often than i'm
rooting for the other girls yeah but
like dorit i love okay and i have to say
something
kyle and shahidah and like the kyle
store opening and like last or maybe two
seasons ago the new york fashion week
show like it's giving oc season one and
beverly hills is like the crown jewel
and all of kyle's like clothing business
ventures like it's not cutting it no i
know and it's so weird like retail is
really not where it's at like obviously
she
learned that in the last few years and
now
that's what she wants to do again it's
surprising and i don't understand
the actual like financial
i think shakita is like a not so silent
partner like i think she has a lot of
money she gives off that vibe like and
so she's just like putting kyle's name
on it kyle's always doing like kyle by
eileen kyle echida right she has like
money partners because she's a rich
woman who knows other rich women yeah
i just don't get the point of it me
neither but jerry looked good in that
outfit she did in the clothes there was
tons i like a store that has a lot of
clothes you go to the store there's
three racks there's more seats and like
plants and there are no sizes and this
store had like full categories like
warehouse vibes leopard
cheetah yeah this that and i it looks
like somewhere you could actually shop
100 just want to say so i can't even
like get into what happened on the couch
but without it being a department store
where there's too much crap crap i can't
really even get into the um the couch
argument because i wasn't able to really
truly follow i just know like crystal
like saw herself in this argument and
decided to get really upset yeah i think
she just was really upset and she
couldn't mask it yeah and she just like
it was just making her leave but also
like some of the stuff she was saying
like i can relate to the idea of like
wow you guys are being hypocrites you're
invalidating sun's feelings like i'm not
exactly i haven't experienced and i
don't even know what i'm thinking about
necessarily but i do feel like sometimes
you see a situation and it's like wow
you guys are handling this so much
differently than like how it was handled
for me so i can i can relate to that but
like when she started being like this
isn't a safe space for me it was giving
distress millennial and i was triggered
and i had to go i had to go too early it
was give safe space i agree like and
then but then i'm sorry then dorit out
out millennialed her when she was like i
can't believe you would use the term
safe space after what i've just been
through like really that's no it was all
very distressed it was giving like it
was toxic woke like my feelings might
yeah like i need to save space on campus
like it was really it was triggering for
me you know like
it i agree but even the fact that you
would call it triggering is like the
same thing yeah of space of safe space
and i i and you know what like maybe she
was valid in those feelings but she did
a horrible job explaining because i have
literally no idea still what she was so
crying about like
agreed so it was um it was a fine
episode i just really do love kyle's
house her dogs eating all the food was
like the best storyline because that's
the most relatable thing to ever happen
on the real housewives of beverly hills
agree but the way those dogs just like
she leaves them at home the whole back
is open yes i was thinking the same
thing oh my god bryce could never no i
would never see bryce again is indoor
outdoor living they go to this um store
opening and she's like hey guys i'm home
and the dogs are in the middle of the
golf course they're like very trained
dogs no they're not that's what she was
saying the whole episode but in the
sense that they're not going to run away
from maybe there's an invisible fence
that's what i was thinking if bryce if i
gave bryce an inch he would take a mile
of course if i let theo run through that
house i would never see him again they
would be on the golf course within their
golf carts like taking selfies and never
see those kids never the brass and
strassen um
and then kathy hilton and paris hilton
were on watch happens live that was a
rerun that was a rerun because i was
like why the [ __ ] is kathy on she wasn't
even in this episode this is paris aired
in november oh i'm sorry no that was
when her wedding was no but it aired
years ago i'm sorry the clip of garcelle
on the reel and kathy was like did you
get your invitation she was like i
literally wasn't invited like that was
so awkward no but that was so cathy so
kathy i don't think she would have said
it i believe kathy that like people
didn't get their invitations
i don't know no i do because why would
she step in it like that cause like she
wasn't thinking no and i'm pretty sure i
saw that look on paris like when she
filmed it
months ago it was a rerun for sure it
was a rerun for sure yeah yeah um and
got mick the bartender was
runner-up of dragon race last season who
won the snatch game by doing paris so
like it's like this iconic like and
gottmick was her makeup artist
oh that was how andy introduced scott mc
it was like we got mc was whose makeup
harris's
at some point or did you do her makeup
for that night annie just said paris is
former makeup artist
what
that is so interesting i didn't know
that
um okay so that's our show our final
show of the week we're back on tuesday
after the long weekend i hope everyone
has a wonderful memorial day stay safe
be with friends be with family enjoy
drinks
drink spritz spritsociety.com our new
variety packs are now available
of course if you happen to find yourself
flying to rome or milan on a united
flight out of chicago or new york this
weekend you will find sprit society for
free on board and in the lounges for i
think three dollars which is a great
price i do hope you find yourself
traveling to milan this weekend yeah
from either o'hare or newark that i love
that for you i love that for you so
we're now aboard united we haven't
spoken about that yet that's i totally
forgot
it's so sickening um the roots are
really specific so
look at the uh but if you're in the
o'hare or
newark lounges they're in the lounges
have fun in milan you guys have fun in
milan
love you guys thank you so much for
listening to the morning show the
millennium morning show where we deliver
the past five stories so you need to
know every monday friday on youtube so
if you're watching this on youtube
please don't forget to subscribe give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available as podcasts anywhere podcasts
we found spotify itunes stitcher public
radio i heart video catbox all the
places so whenever you listen to a
podcast find us more intelligent
five-star review about how to be
beautiful about how stunning and about
how smart we are and an amazing memorial
day can i just say something good which
is that if you're looking for more
content from us for the four days that
we are off patreon.com morning toast has
tons of podcast episodes new podcast
episodes are dropping claudia and i are
about to record one right now that's
going to be so fun so funny we did two
this month that are just general q and
a's with the two of us answering all of
your burning questions we actually
talked about a ton of new stuff that we
don't typically talk about i did an
episode with uh lactation consultant
chantal who has been helping me in my
journey plus the 200 plus episodes that
we've recorded over the last four years
if you are looking for more content it
is all there for you while you miss us
during this long weekend if you're
taking a road trip
perhaps patreon perhaps patreon that's a
great call have an amazing day you guys
i'm ordering lunch and we'll see you
tomorrow yum bye
you